[Music]
once in a while a little voice will pop
in my head and say Dave are you sure you
aren't over blowing any of the big
issues that you talk about maybe the
threat to free speech really isn't so
bad
maybe the assault on open discourse on
college campuses isn't all that terrible
maybe most of the mainstream media isn't
simply pandering for clicks and views
then and it never fails some current
event takes place reminding me that the
issues that we're talking about related
to free speech are not only the most
important issues of the day but perhaps
were actually under estimating the
severity of them without an absolute
protection of free speech first we can't
have debates around any of the other
issues that might be important to you
right now care about Betsy DeVos is
comments on title 9 care about Trump's
decision on daca or global warming as it
relates to the recent spate of
hurricanes your freedom of speech and of
inquiry is what guarantees that we can
have discussions around those issues and
everything else tomorrow former Rubin
Report guests and a friend of mine Ben
Shapiro will be speaking at UC Berkeley
the Internet has been lit about the
pre-emptive protests the counter protest
the safe spaces and the trigger warnings
for this event even before the events
has actually happened sadly in and of
itself none of this impending and hyped
up chaos is new so I wasn't planning on
addressing it before Ben even had the
chance to speak then I saw a tweet from
the Los Angeles Times and I felt I
needed to discuss it with you the tweet
reads quote Berkeley braces for
right-wing talk-show host Ben Shapiro
visit end quote
now this headline doesn't seem too bad
on face value actually it reads very
similarly to how much of the mainstream
news is published these days if you're
looking for it though and I know many of
you are the headline is actually a
loaded combination of subtle bias and
outright fake news Berkeley braces is an
interesting choice of words because
usually in headlines we brace ourselves
for a hurricane or another natural
disaster the attempt here of course is
to compare Shapiro's words with the same
emotional weight as a natural disaster
which can actually
and lives in a time right after two
major storms hurricane Harvey and
hurricane Irma hit the United States
this phrasing is particularly useful as
we are all subconsciously associating
the word brace with death and
destruction if you think I'm overstating
the word brace with hurricanes just do a
Google News search for braces for Harvey
or braces for ArmA and see what pops up
now the Los Angeles Times reader knows
that something so horrible is coming
that UC Berkeley must brace for it as it
would for a deadly hurricane next they
use the pejorative right wing to opine
on Ben's talk-show and his views of
course there's no doubt that as a
conservative Ben's political views are
on the right but there's something else
when they say right-wing virtually every
time the mainstream media uses the
phrase right wing it's to paint someone
as either scary evil or as a racist in
and of itself being right-wing isn't bad
it's just a political view one which you
may or may not agree with but here we
now have students bracing for this right
wing speaker sounds scary doesn't it why
does the mainstream media never label
anyone or anything left-wing when they
want to scare you has an Tifa been
labeled left-wing by the LA Times or CNN
I searched the LA Times calm for those
words together and unsurprisingly it has
not while right-wing is a dog whistle
for bad and left-wing is just left out
altogether when it doesn't fit the
correct narrative you really have a
problem did you see a headline in the LA
Times or CNN that read City University
of New York braces for left-wing
activist Linda Sarsour of course you
didn't and I would argue that Linda's
our sewers ideas are far more dangerous
than anything that ben shapiro talks
about if you think I'm being a bit
melodramatic here consider this as long
as the LA Times is using colorful
language with their headlines why didn't
they add a fun adjective before UC
Berkeley
I mean Berkeley was once the home for
free speech in America and it is now
ACEF
left-wing see I can do it to hate why
not say former school of academic
freedom Berkeley
is for right-wing talk-show host Ben
Shapiro or intolerant of other ideas
Berkeley braces for right-wing talk-show
host Ben Shapiro or even simply and most
honestly and directly if we're being
fair to both sides
left-wing Berkeley braces for right-wing
talk-show host Ben Shapiro certainly
that would be true at least but their
omission of one label while prescribing
another one tells you all you need to
know this headline before Ben has even
spoken tells you a story all right but
it isn't the one that the LA Times
intended the headline tells you the
story of the double standard with which
mainstream conservatives have to deal
with fueled by a media that inflames the
situation when it comes to anyone on the
right but largely ignores it when it
comes to anyone on the left this tricky
use of words and selective writing is
largely what people are talking about
when they talk about fake news the media
should be giving us facts straight up
not editorializing through headlines
that confuse and conflate what's
actually happening on the ground if
you'd like to know more on how the media
confuses us with headlines like this
check out my discussion with Eric
Weinstein on the rustle conjugation and
we'll link to that video right down
below Ben is going to speak at UC
Berkeley and he is going to say some
things that'll trigger some people not
because he's attacking individual people
or because the things that he's saying
are inherently offensive but more so
because he's challenging the social
justice warrior ideology that is
ransacked clear thinking on the college
campus in America if you don't like what
he says write a paper about it invite a
counter speaker or non violently protest
in a way which allows the people who do
want to hear him have a chance to
exercise their right to free speech just
as much as you want to exercise yours
headlines like this subtly excused and
actually helped instigate violence
toward anyone who dares step out of
groupthink I guarantee that the ideas
that Ben talks about tomorrow are in no
way something you have to brace for and
even less something that you have to act
violently towards defending free speech
as a college student now will help
ensure that it will be defended when you
grow out of the groupthink as an adult
so instead of sign
speakers on campus perhaps do what
you're supposed to do in college instead
listen to someone who thinks differently
than you do this way you will learn how
to think and instead of having to brace
yourself for bad ideas you can arm
yourself with good ones joining me today
is co-host of the five host of the Greg
Gutfeld show on Fox News and more
importantly a survivor of the
undergraduate program at UC Berkeley
Greg Gutfeld
finally welcome to the Rubin report
thank you for having me kind of there
even though I'm here but still I still
feel close to you I feel that you are
truly the hardest-working man in show
biz because we tried to coordinate this
for like six months and finally just
getting our schedules lined up but
really more your schedule because you're
doing 87 shows over there for Fox
finally we just conceded and we said
we'll do this over Skype yeah and then I
actually bought a ticket to fly to do
your show and you're not there so I'm
just gonna sit at a hotel I'm gonna sit
at the Sunset Marquis by the pool I
don't care how cold it is and I'm just
gonna get drunk you know what I had a
choice
doing Harvard or talking to gutfeld and
I first before we do anything else I'm
very excited because it appears that
you're in some sort of padded cell over
there which I assume is where they keep
the hosts during the day right this is
this is where it this is where I sleep
until the show's ready yeah it's a it's
a I don't know what this is it's a very
tiny depressing room and it's very humid
but this is where we do podcasts and any
kind of special sky P stuff that's not
high-tech we are here I do like the
artwork behind you though oh thank you I
have a team of people that keep bright
colors behind me so that in the winter
this paleness doesn't you know supersede
anything else so so I mentioned you so
you're a busy guy I mean you're doing a
thousand shows over there even when you
know you've been you've been letting me
I'll use the word letting come on your
show once a month or so which I
absolutely love and it's a it's a what
you're doing is a great blend of
politics and comedy which I think we
need more now than ever but even to
afterwards I'll be like oh you want to
get
you want to hang out but and you're like
I got a tape 87 other things I got the
five now and four here and I got a
report and then you're like you want to
meet at 6:30 in the morning I can meet
you on the corner for I mean how how is
it keeping up with that kind of
production schedule people might see it
on TV and they don't realize like it's
work it really is but to be fair I still
meet up with you like we have met up and
I still AM able to - after doing
everything meet you at a hotel bar and
get slightly inebriated so I I always I
always I always put that as a priority
it's um I I think look I cheat a lot
about which I learned from magazines I
repurpose a lot of material I'll be
honest like I got a do if I gotta do
this show and then I got to do this show
I look at what my notes and I go yeah I
could probably tweak it a little bit why
right why reinvent the wheel if you're
gonna be North doing North Korea on the
five and they're doing North Korea on
the GG show just use the same talking
points just twist them up a little
around if you're gonna use a metaphor
where you're gonna compare him to a
spoiled brat then you could compare him
to a crazy uncle like just changing the
analogies and hope that people don't
notice that you're a hack but do you
ever feel like you're sort of like
stealing from yourself sometimes I'll
tweet something that I said in stand-up
ten years ago and I'm like wait a minute
I just stole that from old Dave that's
why I always do I try to alleviate that
that self-loathing by just slightly
tweaking it and sometimes you know what
happens is you end up finding something
new but I will like I will I'll be
saying something and I go I swear to God
I said that a week ago I think that's
the problem with working a lot doing two
things at a is that you find yourself
repeating and you're like you ask
yourself did I say this already I so god
I hope I didn't say this before and then
I didn't then I and then I realized that
I might have said it two years ago about
the same story it's creepy but you know
people are like you and me would they
don't remember either
like if I don't remember what I've said
if I don't remember what I've said then
they can't remember what I've said Oh
Greg you you underestimate the Internet
they remember everything so it's really
interesting to me because you're doing
two things at least two things over on
Fox so your two main gigs though are the
five and this is a day
panel show everyone's seen it it's
crushing it in the ratings you were on
the 5 right from the beginning right yep
exactly when it was at 5 o'clock and
you'll have a scoop
we were probably I guess moving back to
5 o'clock in a couple of weeks I think
oh right I heard there's someone new
coming to Fox is that public eye I saw
it that's like like everything in life I
see it on like blogs last night I saw it
on media and I think I saw it on CNN and
it was that we're going back to five and
and Laura Ingraham is coming to Fox I
believe at nine o'clock no one has
actually told me this at Fox I've just
read it so I'm just assuming this is the
case you just because every day right
right well you could look you could
either get an internal email or you
could hear it from blogs which seems
better to you exactly I one day I'm
gonna find out that I'm fired on a blog
actually I have a little US we just
heard a little something I but I didn't
want to tell you right now oh wait we
gotta pause for a second it's your 50th
birthday today no it's my 53rd birthday
I'm 53 I know I look like I'm 50 years
younger than I why people tell me that
they tell me that yeah but you know this
is an interesting fact Joe just got born
Donald Trump had a grandson today so his
grandson which is Eric born today will
have the same birthday as mine so I feel
like I'm that much closer to the
administration Wow well you'll
definitely have to leverage that for
something yes yes but I know I noticed
how shocked you are that I'm 53 it's
like I thought 50 makes sense but 53 yes
53 that that seems weird to me so anyway
so you're doing the daily thing on the
five and then so I love doing your show
because you're doing what I think is
sort of how people should ingest
politics with a with some humor but also
on your show because it's a weekly show
you don't have to get slammed with the
day-to-day stuff so I'm curious for you
as someone that's doing both do you like
one more than the other do you find that
sometimes you have to just because of
the nature of cable news and a daily gig
that you have to sometimes talk about
things that maybe you don't particularly
care about like how do you balance all
that for yourself I you know it's you
know that on the five that this is what
you gotta do this is like it's the end
it you got you're going through the
garbage of the day you know what
happened the this what what I look at
the Saturday show as it's kind of like
everything is not so bad come on in sit
down we're gonna talk about how that
week went and we're gonna focus on the
stuff that we remember and the stuff
that makes us nervous and the stuff that
makes us laugh but the bottom line is
unlike the daily new the daily news
programs
we're not here to alarm or upset you
we're here to like just say you know
what it's not so bad so we're going to
go through this North Korea stuff we're
gonna go through Donald Trump stuff
we're gonna go through this and we're
gonna have a good time and have fun and
you're welcome to be here and we want
you to we want you to feel comfortable
there that means the guest should feel
comfortable the audience should feel
comfortable that's why I don't like it
on the show I don't like any conflict at
all i I don't I don't I think maybe in
two years or two and a half years of
doing the GG show I don't think I've
raised my voice in anybody and it's I
just feel like it should like it should
be the way daily conversation is and you
don't yell at people
I mean maybe on a Thanksgiving dinner
you might yell it like the cousin that
comes back from Harvard with a pierced
nose and tell you how capitalism is evil
or is your uncle who's got unusual views
about the past you know right but most
of the time most of them it should be
the way you normally talk with people
and it should be fun and in never boring
it should be interesting
but sometimes that means not doing the
stories that we do every day but trying
to see an overall like it's weird
there's always trends the the trends
about speech like I think we every time
you're on there think of them there's
campus speech or the efforts to silence
speech or anti faso that's always good
to be there then you always have a week
of what Trump did and that I like doing
because it gives you a perspective that
defies what all the other media's do in
the media it's no it's impossible for
Trump to be what they say he is you know
when they're in this hysterical mode
it's like there's no way he's that
person it's just it's it
physically impossible for him to be
Hitler and Bigfoot and you know and and
Charles Manson at once it just is so
when you when I do that long turned back
for in the a block and look at all the
things all of a sudden you realize he's
just kind of a funny 71 year old guy and
you gotta see that like he's not there
it's kind of even Sam Harris said
something in this last podcast with this
German philosopher when the philosopher
was comparing Trump to Hitler and then
Sam Harris was like yeah but you know um
it really hasn't been that I mean there
hasn't been a lot going on he was kind
of dawning on him that maybe the
hysteria is a little much and that's the
first time I've actually seen him do
that yeah you know you're hitting
something really interesting there on
the on the point of the weekly show as
it relates directly to Trump because if
you look on Twitter which I want to talk
to you a bit about that too and you look
on just the general social media stuff
everyone's constantly reacting the media
doesn't give people a chance to react
they get outraged and then they tell you
what they're outraged about because it's
what you're supposed to be outraged
about but in a way by you doing the
weekly thing you're actually removing
the most toxic piece of the equation
yeah yeah it's it's the I I try to the
show for me is to settle down let's just
settle down and like and block out all
that crap because it is crap it's a
study like I don't think you know I did
this study in which I compared people on
Twitter to people off Twitter and the
conclusion is people off Twitter are
better you're a good person on you're a
good person right now in real life
you're not as good on Twitter you're not
you'll never be as good as the person
you are and I know that with myself I'll
look in like tweets I've said because
normally I have to work I'll have a
couple of glasses of wine in the next
and I think I'm so damn clever and then
in the morning I look at my [ __ ] and I
go you know that's not who I am or
that's not even right you know it's
better just to hold those thoughts and
craft them for something else rather
than just spit them out and then wake up
the next day and go you know that's
petty that's stupid
oh here's me trying to appear smart and
funny when
neither and I and then when I see other
people do it like people that I like I
think less of them like a comedian that
I really enjoy and I just go god he's
such an [ __ ] like I gets me so mad
it's just it's so I realized that this
thing makes people lesser people and
yeah you know I don't know and so all
right here yeah yeah stories I hate the
stories that sometimes we might do it on
the 5 or the GG show where you can do
that the Twitter created stories so Dave
room it says this and it creates this
reaction and they've got they start
reading tweets as if that's a story
there's a billion tweets a day and they
come they find six tweets that say Dave
Broome it should be fired reuben should
be fired I hate it it's like oh boy I
bet you know it was a sin it's a sex and
that's the story and then we all comment
on that then that ends up on media right
and then media i gets tweeted and then
it creates this stupid thing that just
keeps going around and around I hate it
and I still I still get suckered into it
like flypaper and this is why Dave Rubin
is his own boss because he's gonna have
to tweet something pretty damn stupid to
fire himself but that that's actually a
perfect segue for where I wanted to go
which was just a little bit about Fox
because you are you're basically the
funny guy at Fox I mean you you offer
comic relief I think Jesse waters does
it a little bit but you're sort of the
main guy and the amount of what I would
say at this point it's sort of similar
to the Trump thing the amount of
unhinged hatred towards Fox now I can
tell you just from my own experiences at
Fox I I did a Reilly show way back when
it was you know we argued actually but
it was a totally pleasant experience
they let me say whatever I want when I
do your show you a hundred percent there
as far as I know you've never edited a
word I say I did Tucker last week it was
live so they let me say what I'm gonna
say so this unhinged hatred of Fox as
someone that works there that's also on
the entertainment side of things how do
you deal with that like with friends and
family and everything else it's a great
question because there's so many facets
to it number one if somebody hates Fox
they don't recognize me so I can why I
can go wherever I want right but but
it's really funny cuz like the people
that watch Fox really like you because
they feel like
they have a connection to you because
they feel like oh my god there's
somebody there that that understands me
so the people who recognize you really
like you there are situations where this
there's this area where they recognize
you and they don't know why and they
it's because they were at their parents
house and you were on the TV and your
dad or your his dad was watching and
your and you're like hi oh god what is
he saying I hate this guy and they see
me and they get the best the best it's
when you get I got recognized at at a
bar in Newark I was waiting for I think
this might have been waiting for my wife
to can fly and I'm sitting at a bar this
guy is just staring at me I've told this
story before it's my favorite story he's
just staring at me and he's he's older
guy he's just holding a beer and he's
really looking at me I go oh god here it
comes here it comes and so he comes over
and he just goes I just want to tell you
I think you should be ashamed of
yourself you should be ashamed of where
you work man I'm just like going I go
all right all right because I don't say
anything cuz it's not worth it and then
he goes what TMZ I realized he thought I
was that guy the dude the guy with a
Slurpee drink 11 I was thinking what a
great opportunity to actually punch this
guy and get Harvey Levin in trouble but
instead I just started laughing and I
just kind of shrugged and then we went
our merry way but it was like it was
really it's the okay you it let's use
comparisons with my wife we go out and
we're with her friends a lot of friends
don't watch Fox some people do so you
get into these weird dynamics of
politics and they find out that you're
not you're a nice guy
and they find out that you're normal and
in the knowledge that then that changes
the way they they think and then they
all of a sudden they are bumming
cigarettes off you and you ended up
going some to some other bar and all
this crap and then that whole thing it's
gone but generally I do sense like a
little bit of a weird resistance and
then they find out that I think I'm sure
a couple of times somebody's gone up to
my wife when they find out who she's
married to
because she works in fashion then go
you're married to him but it doesn't
happen very often it happens enough that
I remember it like once or twice yeah
it's you know I go ahead I don't know if
you know this but jumping back to Harvey
Levin for a second I believe he's
getting like a limited run on Fox News
now did you know about that yeah I
thought that he does that thing about is
it about people's stuff
yeah yeah about their stuff yes so it's
gonna be it's gonna be even worse now
I'm just it's just gonna be they're
gonna just think I'm him but I'm trying
to think there's like no like okay
on Fox I mean when you go on social
networks you're or I'm already used to
that stuff I've been here for ten years
before there was the phrase fake news
there was the paint there was the
opposite which was faux news so it
wasn't always fo f f/a UX is what they
called Fox News so I was always right
people would say you yours
you're scum you work you work for the
Murdock's it's not that's all you get
all that stuff so it's just it's not an
argument so it doesn't it doesn't bother
me like if it's not enough if they're
not coming at me with something where I
was wrong then I don't really care
what's going on in here they're like I
got enough I think I think the Murdock's
just sent you a message I'm not supposed
to say the name Wow shut the lights off
on guy Feld jeez that was incredible
what timing no but um if somebody comes
at me and with an with information that
proves that I'm wrong I actually welcome
it but it makes me sad that I'm wrong
but anything else like you're a horrible
person because that's not an it's not an
argument the one that I get a lot is I
used to think you were funny until I saw
you on Fox or I
you're not funny are you leaning against
the switch
that's my Gabi I think you're leaning
against a light switch are you fired
that was a beautiful that was a
beautiful metaphor for Fox people think
it's the evil Murdock's its Gabi leaning
on this way no but uh Gabi's great she's
my assistant she's from Pottsville
Pennsylvania anyway nothing to do with
what we're talking about but oh my god
what were we talking about we're talking
about Fox
I forgot what you were saying about
about being you don't mind being correct
oh yeah that's when it's when um they
say oh that one the one thing I was
getting at is you're not funny that
happens when people that's when people
don't like what you've said so it's like
instead of disagreeing with you they go
you know you're just not funny it's like
like I've been blocked by comedians on
Twitter which I find odd you know it's
like such a weird thing and Sarah
Silverman blocked me cuz I was like I
people will send me her tweets about Fox
I can't read them and I go I can't read
those unplucked or Lena Dunham has
blocked me which I take as a badge of
honor but it's it's like that's such a
strange thing it's like as I'm not a
comedian I just talk it's this we're the
comedians get so angry over stuff I
can't deal with it I gotta block them
but isn't that sort of exactly the
symptom of what's going on in society at
large like the fact that comics now are
calling for books you know Sarah
Silverman didn't want you don't wanted
to boycott Simon & Schuster because a
milos book now you may hate Milo
but the eye can you imagine George
Carlin ever being like we're gonna ban
books it's frightening and it's like I I
think we talked about it a tab at the
bar something I kind of remember that
comedians in general aren't doing enough
in this arena to mock this you hear
about comedians saying they're not doing
college campuses anymore I think even
know if it was Seinfeld or yeah yeah
this is not worth it just not where that
I don't need to I don't need the trouble
you say one thing you know it's like
well actually you should be the one that
says we got to stop this but I know that
he's made enough money doesn't need to
do that but younger comedians should be
over there going out and like saying
screw this I know there's a there's a
First Amendment tour going on but then
it's not comedians it's Camille Paglia
and jeez I hate bringing up stuff that I
don't remember but Camille Paglia is the
headliner and they're just speaking and
it's just basically a big fu to what's
going on comedians should be doing that
they should be doing comedy roasts on
campus you know like just like the
Jeffrey Ross stuff they should be doing
that on campus on purpose make them as
disgusting as possible well it's funny
because the the
isn't exactly my my old stand up ground
where I where I was doing stand-up in
York for 12 years but I am doing the
college thing now and it's like by
default I'm becoming funny again in a
weird way because because everyone else
is so hysterical and these kids are just
sitting there going it can't be this bad
and that there's so there's fertile
ground for comedy there it's interesting
if you see like you'll see it on YouTube
there'll be a comedian on stage and
everybody's laughing
but he'll say one thing and then
somebody in the audience is upset so now
you have to worry about like the
singular offensive things like it's like
you could make you could be it'd be like
you like making a joke about herpes and
somebody getting up and going oh that's
not funny now you know okay we now we
know who has herpes but it's like but
it's like as a comedian now you're
supposed to think that like okay I got
to worry about every single person in
there there might be a cat lover if you
if you are like if you don't like cats
and you say suck I mean it used to be
people are supposed to park that stuff
outside and again the audience all that
shit's out there I can take a joke but
now people are encouraged to bring their
there their pain into a company club and
oh here you how dare you say this or
that you know but not only are they not
only they bring in their pain and
they're also bringing their phone so
it's like in the old days okay if you
brought your pain in well then you could
heckle and okay that's it
now you can live stream your pain and
get extra extra social justice what's
all right let's shift from there for a
second yeah so I mentioned I mentioned
up top that you were an undergrad at
Berkeley we've been talking a little bit
about the college thing for a second
so what years were you at Berkeley I
can't do the math off the top of my head
83 83 to 87 yeah so that yeah it was
back in the glory days of New Wave by
the way that's why I went to Berkeley
was I had to I was either gonna go to
University of Santa Clara which is a
smaller private school in Palo Alto or
say well obviously Santa Clara more
Berkeley but Berkeley had the best
record store
and I used to go every weekend from San
Mateo drive over the bridge and go to a
Rasputin wreck they had Rasputin records
Tower Records and there was a third one
I camera that's why I chose Berkeley
because I just like to buy records and I
was kind of liberal but I didn't even
know what politics I didn't know what
politics really was so it wasn't for I
didn't even know the history of Berkeley
when I got there I had no clue it was
this radical Bastion I until he started
taking classes but I didn't even
understand what I was being taught like
I had a lot of deconstruction and a lot
of like deconstruction informed in all
parts like you if you took a Bible class
it was deconstruct anything but I didn't
really know what it was I just learned
to ape it you know would you figure it
out how to do it you can get aids that's
so that's what I did so so you come in
and I sense him from what I've read also
I did read your wikipedia you didn't
care that much you didn't care and I
assume it's on Wikipedia it's true
you didn't care that much about politics
specifically then you get there you kind
of realize you're being inundated with
this stuff when did you have that shift
that sort of put you do you can I guess
you consider yourself a libertarian now
right yeah yeah you know when were using
labels yeah I would say this okay when I
was in high school I considered myself
Oh like every high school kid I was like
a radical I worked for the nuclear
freeze so I was political but it was
only for grades so it was like I was
like I wasn't afraid I was an
opportunistic leftist when I got to
Berkeley I saw the real ones man I saw
the group think that I'd never seen
before
I'd never seen just one mass of people
thinking the same way and it it was
scary they used to have marches about
all sorts of stuff and I didn't like I'd
be walking home from the library and
just people yelling at me like and I
have no idea what's going on that that
was like I I'm not like that I'm not
like this I'm not political but I'm also
I'm like what is this and is this all
there is and then a friend of mine this
guy Patrick came home and he and he had
like two magazines with him he had
national review in the American
Spectator and at the time the American
Spectator was his oversized broadsheet
then both of them had sections in
that were actually funny PJ O'Rourke
wrote for American Spectator and Nast
review had some genuinely funny I mean
Buckley was funny when they had his
little sections of short news called
this week which was a national view and
then the American Spectator just had
like great writing throughout Tom Wolfe
Joe Queen and all this enough and I read
and that was like it was like I didn't
know this stuff existed I had no clue
that this was and I started subscribing
to that and then by my senior year I
applied for an internship at the
American Spectator and that would be
kind of my quasi first journalism job
even though all I was was a guy who
fetched cigarettes for editors and
accounts it counts yeah it does count it
was like a year of driving my boss
around in his diesel Mercedes yeah yeah
that's what happened so what do you
think happens sort of to that that sort
of conservative or libertarian thinking
that was making sense to you it seems to
me that probably a little bit after that
and maybe a little more towards the the
GW Bush portion of the 90s where the
Christian conservatives sort of really
took a hold of the party that it really
probably changed at least what I would
argue are probably like sensible
libertarian things did you see a shift
like how long were you cool with what
was going on before maybe you weren't or
maybe you were the whole time I don't
know I you know what I realized that the
newer you are to politics the more
likely you are dedicated to a certain
side including libertarianism like you
anew meet a young libertarian there and
there is a note there is annoying as a
young leftist or a young bright winger
everybody's annoying if they if they put
themselves in a box and they're shouting
in the box I think it had to do with
like seeing again moralism a certain
kind of moral ISM which was a mirror the
left wing moralism the right wing
moralism they're both kind of the same
thing it I realized I would I so as I
became a you know into the libertarian
area era which was be just wanting to be
left alone and not understanding why
people go to jail for stuff in which
they're just trying to find pleasure in
life whether it's drugs or prostitution
these are things that I mean like these
are decisions that a human
can make on their own and and how you
how you could be punished for certain
these things just it that made me more
of a libertarian however people would
argue I'm not a libertarian because I'm
for a pretty strong National Defense and
I'm you know I I'm I'm you know I'm for
surveillance you know I'm I'm so and I
think it's because I I mean I've been so
focused on terror for for the lot for
since since 2001 that is my I always
tell myself I'm a libertarian with a lot
of guns you know or a libertarian with a
new we I feel that you need to have
national security in order to have
freedom the we always libertarians will
put them as opposing things you know
that Benjamin Franklin quote if you
sacrifice one for the other you have
neither yeah I think they go hand in
hand they walk can't their siblings that
if you want freedom you got to have you
got to you got to be able to fight for
it so they go together some people might
say legitimately that I go too far I
have friends who say I go too far no the
people that I work with go like you know
you are overstating the threats of
terror and I and I might I always see
terror like terror is my global warming
people who are into global warming like
the world's gonna end I'm like that I
really believe terror is an X all it's
gonna take is one guy with a dirty bomb
that's what I think about and and I read
too I read a lot on it and it fills up
my brain sometimes maybe I get a little
too crazy yeah so I'm kind of with you
on my belief and I as a classical
liberal or a libertarian or whatever
that space holds right now my belief is
that the strong military thing I'm a
hundred percent for it because I believe
if you have a strong military most
likely you don't have to use it it
doesn't mean you should just use it to
do whatever the hell you want all over
the world early a nation build and all
that but hopefully it causes some
deterrence the surveillance thing I'm
probably a little more center than you
but it's interesting that you're
offering a little caveat they're saying
maybe you are seeing it I like that
someone that's honestly saying my lens
of this maybe could shift or maybe is a
little blurry or whatever yeah I mean I
I have to be you know I have to be open
to being wrong about a lot of things
because I know when I've been wrong you
know
I'm trying to think of an example no
gutfeld please I have a list here you're
gonna make me do this but you know what
if you know it's like you know let's say
let's say something like stop and frisk
I mean has how stopping stop and frisk
in New York has it had a negative effect
I don't know I don't know for that I was
for stop and frisk but I don't know if
you're seeing if you're seeing a
negative impact
I think the murders are down I I think I
don't know about if they they probably
confiscated less guns right I hope gun
crime has gone up but I'm pretty sure
overall maybe murders gone down in New
York it's gone up in other parts of the
country but I think New York had stayed
down but I'm not sure I'm not sure about
murder in New York but I'm pretty sure
crime overall in New York City is way up
isn't it is it I don't know you know see
it I could be wrong about being wrong
maybe maybe I was right about stop and
frisk now I just aided and abetted
you're wrong yes you see what we've done
here we're going to admit being wrong
again I think though I think the murder
rate is lower but there's you know rape
is up and they're trying to that's um
that's an interesting thing because
they're not sure if it's because of
reporting more or what but that's been
that's been a disturbing thing that's
been happening I know I have that right
I think I have that statistic right I
should you know I I don't give too much
cred to YouTube these days
with everything that's going on on
demonization all that nonsense but I
know that my audience on YouTube is good
enough that they are gonna fact-check
the hell out of the two of us right
there and you know what if someone can
give me something real in the comments
down below we'll pin it up top and then
we'll make fun of gutfeld for the rest
of the month and I will come back and
admit that I was wrong but I always I
always say I may be wrong because I may
be wrong it's like it's like why do you
have to be I don't understand and the
desire to always be right I mean it
feels good but it's also good to learn
something also you can be better at
being right if you let people help you
you know I'm still open on the climate
change stuff I'm always interested in
finding something else that can help my
brain because I'm I am you know I'm in
that world where I like I was again
the climate Accords but that doesn't
mean I don't think climate change is a
hoax you know I think that there's the
it's too complex
yeah wait let's just dive into that real
quick so without going too deep on the
science of it is easier feeling is your
feeling on that that as a libertarian
you just don't think this is something
the government can really handle and yet
you're acknowledging science as is yeah
I think it's weird it's like which
drives me crazy whenever we do climate
change on the five it'll be one segment
six minute segments I end up reading for
four hours and it destroys my whole day
because what happens is that talk about
a rabbit hole yeah the site that you'll
have some really elegant work on on how
climate change is real and then you look
at the you go into the hurricane stuff
and they go well co2 is rising but the
Hurricanes aren't in it then and there's
an elegant work on that too and then you
read and scientists are going like we
can't say for certain that these
hurricanes are the cause of man-caused
climate change but it could be and then
you kinda need so you end up there and
then you see like Oh is there a pause
well you'll see this work saying there's
a pause and then there's work that says
there's no pause there's a slight
increases and those increases mean
everything and then you the person I
read all the time is Bjorn Lomborg
Lomborg have you ever read him I have
he's like the he's like to me the most
sensible he's not what you call a
lukewarm ER you know he's not a skeptic
he's not an apostle
he's a lukewarm ER and he talks about
like you know what is the rete what
realistically can you do and and why he
was a big critic of the climate the
Paris Accords and then to spend like a
hundred trillion over a hundred years
and you're not gonna see any effect is
kills people is what his but kind of
what he was saying if you took that
money he listed like ten things you
could eradicate completely including
starvation with that money but instead
we're gonna just take all of that to try
and move that this thing a little bit
and not even sure if that's gonna have
an effect so I think that's when you
marry to the economics
in the context of what you could do
better in this world then it starts to
make more sense and I and I do think
it's a I think it was unfair in the
groupthink world of climate change to
ridicule and mock who could smell that
day that not everything is what it seems
not the people that say oh it's a hoax
I'm just saying people like me that are
going like wait a second I've been
through this before I've seen this in
I've seen this growing up with the Ice
Age I've seen it when I worked in health
magazines the types of fads that right
like nobody cares everybody was high
carb when I was at Men's Health right
and and and and and you know cut out
your protein and now you realize it's no
that's you want to lose weight you got a
you know the eat meat even though I
don't know but my point is I kind of
sense when everybody's saying the same
thing that it's not really all that it
seems that people are saying the same
thing in order to belong and to avoid
being criticized and it kind of builds
on itself and the climate change debate
it builds people go well I got if I'm
gonna be if I'm gonna be liked in
Hollywood I gotta say this but I'm going
on the Bill Maher show I got to say this
so not it builds its own mentality and
you start to think that it's not that
simple but if you say that people are
gonna attack you you just go I don't
want to talk about it yeah people don't
want to talk about it the point is
Gutfeld whether you have the yolk in the
egg or you only eat the white you are
going to drop dead one way or another
all right so my last thought on the the
climate change thing is you know that Al
Gore mr. climate change he did sell
Current TV which was his cable news
network to the government of Qatar which
is the world's biggest or second-biggest
oil exporter so the point is I think
we're all a little kind of in the weeds
on this one fair to say I think so he
also if he had been right about climate
change he couldn't have made a sequel
because we would have we would have been
dead so the only way he could make a
sequel if he was if he was wrong in the
first movie are you saying he's doing
the producers is that what you're saying
yes or I guess it's like the reverse
producers in a weird way or something
like that I I think from climate change
a good a good
Segway is to just to news in general so
as a guy that that works at Fox you're
in the cable news thing I think the
question I get more than anything else
these days is who do you trust
how do you figure out when you're going
through the research on what you're
going to talk about on the five or what
you're gonna cover on your show how do
you figure out what's actually legit
well that's interesting because I never
I mean I I read this stuff and then I
talked to people then I asked them if
what they think we have up we have
people at Fox we have something called
the brain room if I'm if I'm skeptical
of a number and they're like they're
good this is like a group of people in a
room that just spend all day fielding
questions that's why they're called the
brain room and if I have a problem with
something I'll go to him but if I smell
anything I won't touch it like if
there's if there's a story that I just
go if something sounds too good then
it's you know it's not it's just too
perfect and you always like there's
weird stories like where you go will you
find like woman's child sent home for
singing America the Beautiful while
petting a kitten well you know what I
mean it's a it's like it always it
sounds like just such perfect red meat
and then you find out somebody makes a
few phone calls you find out it's not
true they kid like you know punch some
kid it's suspended a lot of these
stories that sound like they would be
perfect
never pan out so I just I think I'm just
super skeptical of everything and and
I'm careful oh you probably the best
thing to do is you let a story breathe
for a couple of days never be the first
one never jump on something because
you're it's like every I regret every
time I've ever jumped on a story because
it's never been right it's this has to
have happened and there you go it's like
you know when you get I hate to admit
this like getting--getting falling for a
hoax like yeah I I think I fell for
something there was a hoax on Twitter
about a Burger King
remember the Burger King tweets the guy
in Hong Kong the Burger King tweets and
he was right he was ready Burger King
tweets in him he was going
life is horrible and I thought this was
oh my god and it turned out it was this
guy had been hoaxing for like six months
I go that okay he got me so I have to
like I have to
I always said go like okay this if this
it just is too delicious a story wait
two days I won't do it on any show
that's the other benefit of doing a
weekly show is you get to kind of come
in and and see the mistakes then
everybody else made and go ah look look
what he did he thought it was real like
hopes yeah I'll like take a like hate
crime hoaxes are a good example like if
they just wait a couple of days
something happens and it just like yeah
like I knew it you know well the one
that always sticks with me is remember
the clock boy who got you know kicked
out of school and everyone was going on
and on about this is based in racism and
Islamophobia and all this stuff but if
you looked at what he brought into
school it looked like a bomb I mean it
just it just did and we live in a time
when they say if you see something say
something
so if a little white girl had brought
that thing in you know or a little white
boy that's those are the people the left
thinks are evil so you shouldn't they
have called in on that and then of
course there was a ton other shady
things that happened after this area
president obviously running for
president of I can't remember was in
Afghanistan I can't remember but he yes
I think the family moved to Qatar and so
and all that but even that doesn't
matter but I just remember thinking
during that thing that you the media
portrayed it in such one way that if I
even had tweeted well just everything
aside I don't want this kid to be
treated differently but everything aside
if a kid any kid of any color brings
something that looks like a bomb it
didn't look like a clock it looked like
a bomb through school you would want
that would just be teachers doing their
due-diligence but I didn't even want to
touch it because I didn't want to deal
with this and you know it was
frustrating because President Obama
touched it he oh yeah say like I'm gonna
invite he could be his son or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like I'm gonna
invite yeah I think he was saying that
he said something he didn't fight him to
the White House it for something and it
was like you know that's dated but it
just shows you that you can have these
blinders on and not see like you know
that there's a possibility that this is
a hoax and that there's something going
on but no
you you just he's in the he's in the
Islamophobia bubble where you know
everybody has terrible intentions rather
than just trying to be safe they see
something that looks like a bomb
that's not Islamophobia but he says oh
this poor kid is being targeted because
he he's just doing a science project you
know and it's like no people were just
worried that's what they're supposed to
do it looks like a bomb so his bubble
prevented him from seeing them no no how
do you blend some of the I've said to a
couple people when I when I do your show
that one of the things that I like is
because you kind of you're like doing
the cable news thing and you get the
online thing like this for example when
you when you go up to your PR people or
whoever handles coordinates your stuff
do they say to you gutfeld you can't say
this or don't touch this or anything
you've been remotely close to that
because I think that's what a lot of
people think is happening it at Fox and
a lot of the other evil networks
I think they you know they're pretty
free about it you know no one has ever
told me not to say anything you know and
and and I thought how when I swear on
Twitter I usually get a light I used to
get a little grief like do you really
have to say that I'm gonna go I go look
I know it's I have a theory known
theories on swearing that I don't
understand I don't understand the
concept of swearing like like what does
this word do we're all like don't swear
in front of my children your kids are
going to swear so what you're trying to
do is just put it up as long as possible
don't swear in front of my kid go you
know in five years your kid's gonna be
swearing anyway so it's like everybody
swears it's like pooping in fact it's
it's just like pooping it's therapeutic
you can't hold it in if you keep holding
it in it's like if you couldn't swear
what would you do if you stubbed your
toe you would punch somebody
so the swearing keeps you from punching
people just like pooping that was a
terrible analogy but there's always one
moment in a show where I go ah we got
the promo clip for Twitter and I feel it
was looped around that pooping analogy
it always ends up there I apologize but
people always
tell me too many poop jokes and that was
an apple jack but like that's that's an
issue with no before yeah yeah it was it
was a useful metaphor right yeah that
what you said I I said it was a poop
metaphor not a useful metaphor poop but
swearing like I I find it weird that we
pretend that swearing doesn't exist you
know what I mean it's just an onion when
we like you'll be on TV if you if I
swear on TV I I will get fired or I'll
get suspended but all of us when we go
out into the green room or go somewhere
else we're just like what you know
whatever we're saying when it's just
such a weird thing to say well we have
to pretend like the world out there is a
different world and I get it it's
because you're in somebody's living room
and you should respect their living room
and be polite but sad but but I just
don't see how swearing is rude I don't
understand it yeah but is that is that
kind of one of the inherent problems of
not necessarily cable news but
television news in general that it's
creating this fake thing like I get what
you're saying about the the living room
and trying to be respectful of people
and I don't curse that much every now
and again I drop the f-bomb if I think
it's particularly appropriate but then
when you have this sort of fake guarded
thing coming through the television then
people go online they see this
completely unfiltered thing now it could
be filled with nonsense and lies and
fake names and BS and all that but
they're going at it at least seems a
little more real than the guy who can't
curse but you know what the flip side of
that is when you look at somebody's
description on Twitter god-fearing
grandparents of three lovely children
and their writing [ __ ] you burn in hell
on Twitter and it's like it's like okay
you're a guide like it's so funny to see
that like so that tells you that
everybody swears yeah everybody swears
but anyway it's real to me because I
love that I love that crew I love that
crew the the tolerance Peace Love in the
Twitter handle it's me it's amazing that
they forget they wrote that up there and
they're saying terrible things in their
tweets it's it's always really I mean
it's a lot of people do a tour of my you
always like what somebody said something
horrible to you
remind them what's in there what's in
there below their avatar it's like you
do realize that you say that you're like
loving this and loving that and you know
or I'll ask them if they're if they're
kids if they write to me on Facebook I
ask that I always tell them I'm gonna
put this on your Facebook page and then
they always apologize cut felt I think
we've learned something here which is
Twitter is destroying the country it is
it is the it is did I say this here are
on break that I yeah I did a study yes I
think I did do that that the people on
Twitter yeah that was here that was here
good job did I tell you that ik this is
what happens is I can't remember what I
said this just happened but nope you
know what not remembering not
remembering what you said also has to do
with Twitter as someone that just took a
month off doing that short nonsense all
the time it's like sir it's
short-circuiting all of our brains you
know yeah it's uh it's so gross it's
like I don't feel good after it I just
don't feel good about myself or the
world when I'm on there it's but you
know there's been a lot of unfortunate
events in the last month and whether we
have the Hurricanes and you see like I
think I said this on the 5 you see so
many inspirational acts during the
hurricane you see you know blacks
carrying whites whites carrying blacks
old ladies and young people and all this
stuff and then you go in Twitter and you
can realize okay what's real is what
people see like you can't like when
you're talking to somebody you treat
them as a human being on Twitter you
don't so you get the contrast of how
horrible people are on Twitter is
precisely because they're not having the
human contact like a person could save
another person's life and those two
people could hate each other on Twitter
you know it's because it you have to
have for the sake of evolution and you
know this that you have to have eye
contact in hundred see people granted we
our community our animals of
communications so this is what we do and
it's not going to change
it's just that will we get any better or
are we gonna get worse that's what
scares me
on that note let's shift away from
talking about Twitter how about that
every day I say I'm getting off it and I
don't yeah I'm a jerk you know what
we'll we'll revisit this in a couple
months and
where we're at do what you did I'm gonna
take a month off but I don't I don't
know if I can but I am two weeks I'll
take two weeks yeah do you ever feel
just putting the side social-media do
you ever feel that exhaustion of the
news I I got a lot of that when I jump
back on I got so many emails from people
just saying man I wish I could do that
even for three days or even when I was
away the amount of people that were
staring at their phones you know of
course they're taking selfies and all
that nonsense but just you're I was on a
beach in Mexico for a couple days and at
one of the cafes they had CNN playing I
had to make sure not even to go in there
it's like why would you want to be on a
beach in Mexico and watching CNN it's
pretty it's freaky
there it's like ah you gotta get it yeah
I always feel like it's so much but then
something else happens and then you
forget about what just happened that's
the weird thing is that the cycle is so
fast it wasn't always like that that was
what was interesting about the hurricane
was that that was the first story that
we had a focus on for more than two days
it went on for like with the Houston
hurricane we got Harvey we at we spent
eight days on that and then we went
right into Erma that's it that's the
first time in a long time since probably
the Trump Mia well I guess the election
that we spent every day on one thing we
didn't cover anything else
baby that's healthy that like it we
re-engineered my brain a little where I
had to concentrate but I do get I get I
don't really watch TV when I get home I
like like a set like I'll watch Bar
rescue what do you call it when they're
just just over and over again
it's just they keep date they had them
overlap no I can't like I just sit there
I haven't seen this bar yet and I just
watched the marathon and all of a sudden
it's like 9 o'clock at night
I just watched like 12 episodes and some
of them I'd seen before if you you know
listen if you think you're dealing with
some filth in the news I mean that Jon
Taffer guy he's going to the back of
those bars there is some nasty it would
make you never want to go to a bar again
there is some man Fuji now he's like
what do you think he's gonna die because
this girl and you think they're gonna
get in a fight and then they're and then
all of a sudden are they hug and
everything's good
and they always find dead bugs in an inn
and there's always a rodent under a sofa
and I look and I know that show
backwards and foots the forwards net
it's like and then they turn around for
the surprise and like that that
surprised it's just another bar there's
always a mouse in the refrigerator in
the back but actually that bit there's
something interesting you're hitting on
there I think a little bit like when a
guy like him you know he's doing
obviously it's not news it's it's a
reality show but the yelling cuz in in
cable news when when you know you know
some of these people I don't need you to
call out anybody at your network or even
another network but although feel free
to if you'd like to but how much of it
for these guys for a lot of these guys
do you think is theater versus actually
knowing what they're talking about or
caring what they're talking about
because what I think is that a lot of
people the average person doesn't
realize how much actually is pure
theater for ratings that at the end of
the day these networks they need views
they need eyeballs they need clicks and
if they're gonna give a guy who's gonna
calmly explain an issue and say you know
what climate change I believe in science
but I think that maybe you know they're
they're forcing something down whatever
it is right that guy is always gonna be
rammed to the bottom of the pack by the
guys who's gonna scream yeah it's and it
might be a wrong assumption to think
that like a Booker goes get this guy oh
he's great
and you go why is he great and oh you
got a huge for you should see him on
this show but that I think it's might be
changing because I think the audience
attitudes are changing they I don't
think they like the yelling anymore yeah
I don't you don't have as many crossfire
moments yeah and when you do it and like
I know from the 5 when there's a
crossfire moment the response the
audience doesn't like media I will put
it up there up so it so melts down blah
blah but the audience doesn't like it
they're like going calm I had to turn it
off when you and one yell at each other
I have to turn it off that's what
they'll say and I got and remind myself
how did how did we get to the point were
yelling funny thing is like when it
happens on the 5 it is real it's like
when we're yelling it's actually real
some other shows that might not be I
think old school shows that were like
you know I think it's I think it's
changed
it's funny that when you think about
like the
assumptions of producers they assume
that like Jon Taffer has to yell all the
time
right because that that's drama but I
don't I don't like or else they have the
weird sinister music when you like it
sounds like a door creaking or yeah or
that they have to show transition from
night to day all the stuff that they use
they think is what is what we want when
no we would like something different
we're we're bored with these we don't
need somebody yelling like it's like
Kitchen Nightmares what's-his-face
he's British he's British he's got blond
hair he's British somebody help me help
me gordon ramsay gordon ramsay yeah you
used to do Kitchen Nightmares and then
that didn't change I don't know the name
of it here but it's a Hell's Kitchen or
something I don't know but you do
exactly the formula and after a while
it's like you know this was good for
four shows but you got to like mix it up
but I think table news is like I I I
think it you know it's I think we're
sensing things are changing I think I
finally like you know it's I find Tucker
to be the most interesting interviewer
yeah like no notes like and he just
stares at the person what I do you've
been on my show I have 33 pages of notes
you have so much freaking paper there
how many trees do you kill you you're
literally it looks like it looks like a
beautiful mind on your desk you're
scribbling everywhere you're drawing
sharks kimberly guilfoyle calls me that
because I have like all this stuff it's
only because I have I don't want to miss
anything and of course I do because I
have an idea or in Dead Eye all these
ideas so I write them all down and I end
up having like 20 ideas and then I never
get to them because you guys have to
talk so I'm just like I don't even know
why that's there Tucker just sits there
and he just stares I always say he's
like a dog watching a dryer you know
stairs and he's got this look and it's
the most intense interview like you
could tell he's in the moment like I'm
not in the moment I'm never I'm always
ahead I'm always somewhere else trying
to figure out what's what am I gonna ask
Cyrus what am I gonna do here blah blah
blah but he's just like so focused on
the guest it's unbelievable and he's
like actually listening to every single
word I find that like that's
not me I try to listen wait a minute
you're telling me you're not listening
to the brilliance that I bring to the
gut yes I listen actually I listen to
good guests guess who aren't good I'm
too busy trying to figure out how to get
to the end of the break boy this is this
person isn't working out I'm sure you've
had that look what a person isn't
working out and you're like oh god how
do I get how do I get from here to there
well every now and every now and again
I'll have a guest that I'll just be like
you're just not saying anything you know
like sometimes people are just talking
but they're not really getting anywhere
and I try to lead them into something
and they still can't get there fortunate
doesn't have it doesn't happen that
often because I think we we select
pretty well but of course you're gonna
get that but you know your point on on
Tucker is interesting because you know I
was on there last week and I've been on
a couple of times and generally because
of the free speech stuff I'm not the
type of guest he's bringing on to hammer
but I always think it's amazing when
when he brings on these people that
should know what he's about to do and
it's like they just walk in there as if
it's gonna be like kumbaya and next
thing they know it's like you're
dragging out of corpse yeah did my
favorite one was the guy who thought he
could out Tucker Tucker Kurt I can Wald
do you remember the one he brought a
stack of paper he said the and he was
like he brought a prop and it was one of
the most embarrassing things because all
Tucker did was laugh at him it was it
was just so it was painful they should
do a compilation as like when he goes on
off one night they should do Tucker's
like most amazing interviews and just
have like I'm all like all of these like
crazies where the people come in and
think I'm gonna be the guy I'm gonna be
the guy that that a beats him or B he
likes or whatever and he's just it's
just like you don't know where he's
gonna go and then I just look really bad
so so speaking of Tucker one as I said
before one of the reasons I like doing
this stuff right so you're the Greg
Gutfeld show is not it's live to tape
but it's not aired live when you do the
five it is aired live Tucker's live and
I always my gut feeling my gut feeling
you got that has anyone ever said that
to you before the gut feeling my gut
feeling is I like I like live live
straight up because I know I'm not gonna
be messed with now I know your guys
aren't gonna mess with me or edit me or
anything like that
but when you're doing the live thing
when you're on the five yuvan you've
already had said that you know you're
not going to get everything right all
the time and you're happy to be
corrected but have you ever just by the
nature of the way the human mind works
started saying something and by the time
the sentence finished realize that you
just completely had no idea what you
were saying or something like that like
yeah you see this a lot that all these
people that have to talk all the time
every now and again you start saying
saying and as it's coming out of your
mouth you go oh man I just stepped in it
yeah yeah yeah it's always it's like a
it's just best at that point to trail
off it's just like and just take the
embarrassment rather I'm going in a
really bad direction you know it's funny
though I've noticed that whatever you
think is really bad is less bad than you
think sometimes it's like oh geez think
and then nobody noticed that but
there'll be something else that you
don't think is a big deal and that's the
one that gets picked up and people say I
can't believe you said that and that's
not what I meant and that gig that gets
twisted and turned you make an ironic
joke that they'll think you were serious
like like you were making fun of a
person who might say that you might
maybe like you might you're mocking a
sexist by saying something sexist and
then someone will say no you're sexist I
go no I was actually pretending to be
sexist oh forget it I can't do this I'm
like there's no way I'm gonna get out of
this so I just stop you know that just
happened that just happened to me I
can't remember what I was complimenting
I was complimenting somebody about
saying she she is a really tough person
she'd be a great prison guard and some
how can you say that and I go it's a
compliment it's like what I could say I
could see this oh that's terribly you
would say that I don't know that's a
compliment in an odd way that shows
their sex and because shouldn't be
shouldn't women be allowed to be prison
guards or anything they want to be
that's what I should have said by the
way you know it's pretty it's pretty
funny when we couldn't remember Gordon
Ramsay a minute ago you said before what
do you call that room of people with the
facts what do you say that was the brain
room the brain room I've just got a
window here where a guy yells at me so
it's like it's a little it's a little
different
alright so just to kind of wrap we could
do this all day and it's it's always a
pleasure talking to you and all that
stuff and we will do this in person for
sure but I want to end on because we've
only said the T word the the Trump word
I think it was only lasted for about 20
seconds and I do want to talk about it
for a second because I don't think you
were at least at first a huge supporter
I think you basically when I've done
stuff with you I sense that you're
really trying to make some sense of
what's going on here I think you kind of
get the way he's playing the media which
I've tried to address to me they're all
liars he's just lying in a different way
but he is lying too and what what at
this point is your is your end answer
with him or at least what are you
feeling right now I think he is doing a
pretty decent job when he lets things do
their job I think like the Hurricanes
and stuff the preparations but then he
kind of steps in it and that and then
that creates a lot of mistakes and a lot
of a lot of conflict but I have to say
that he's doing okay I decided to give
him the benefit of the doubt when he
became president we're not when there
are other options I was going like I had
I I pretty much was thinking Rubio I
like me and I was like Jim Webb that was
at that his name James Webb yeah Jim
Webb yeah that point that poor guy he
was running for a party that left like
40 years before you know he was just an
interesting guy you know but anyway um I
had to like you know I was going like my
problem with Trump is that it was taking
ideas that I and other people have
talked about it and kind of like
treating them roughly so that like it
doesn't sound as good except that he's
making it persuasive to a certain group
of people but he's making it he's he's
twisting it in a way that is not as
elegant I guess and that would drive me
crazy it's like it's like ah that's now
that's not how you should do it and then
I realized that a lot of times I'm not
getting it that he's he's taking it in a
different he's taking it to a different
audience it's like when he was making
jokes that I that people were upset
about about like McCain and I was I
thought that was a poor joke to make
then I realized if it was a roast it was
a great joke like if he had said
you know it would have been it would
have and that's how he thinks he feels
that he's a performer out there and he
doesn't really mean it
he doesn't mean that he's not a hero
it's just an insult that would have
worked on a Comedy Central Roast for
Senator McCain if he said ah he's not
everybody says he's a hero but you're
not here if you don't get caught people
would have laughed I suddenly when I
took it out of the context of politics
and put it in that context I saw what he
was when I realized what a different
what a different kind of candidate he
was and how different that was to me and
then I had this real is realization that
why a lot of people on cable didn't like
him was that he was the first cable news
for actually the first Fox News
president he took incorporated a lot of
stuff that he had been been ingesting
for a decade and he made it he turned it
he put it through his filter and then
became this phenomenon and I think you
know I had one talk-show host say to me
I could have done that like he's talking
about himself
well you didn't he did and that's why I
think like I don't know I don't talk to
Glenn Beck but I kind of think Glenn
Beck it was looking at this and going
like there for the I could have done
that why didn't I knew that I had the
following I could have done that but I
didn't he did it and it kind of bugs me
and it's like I think we're seeing a guy
that took ideas that you know that were
I think even from shows that he watched
on Fox mm-hmm and then he went out there
and he performed and he did a you know
he did a phenomenal job I mean it was so
phenomenal that it surprised everybody
yeah go ahead that's the in just quickly
that's the interesting thing is I'll see
people say well you know I'm actually
okay with what he's done or hasn't done
or I'm okay with some deregulation or
the title 9 thing actually was bad or
whatever else but then they'll say oh
well I wish he could just stop tweeting
and I'll go yeah like I don't really
like the tweets I don't comment on them
because I'm not trying to add to the
madness but how can you tell the guy who
did it his way and one despite all odds
well now just do it the way everyone
wants you to it just doesn't stand to
reason regardless what you think of
trauma yeah exactly you know what I was
thinking about this the other day I was
going I was critical of his behavior
although his behavior was very similar
to my own
and I'm wondering like I'm I've said
cruel things I've said tacky things
onset speeches i-i've made inappropriate
jokes and I wondered if I went if I ran
for president would I change my behavior
I probably I probably wouldn't so how
can I blame him for not changing his I
mean how could I yeah how can I blame
him for not being him he's himself
saying did you just did you just
announce for 2020 is that what just
happened there yes exactly
no there's no way I will ever run for
office I wanted to run for mayor I keep
thinking about that of New York as I
can't stand the Blasio but I don't you
know I just don't have the I'm you know
what I'm low-energy Greg I'd say I'm
low-energy Greg I just don't have the
energy it's like that's again one of the
great labels of 20 of 2016 Low Energy AB
but no it's there yeah not me maybe yes
and you should may I mean if I go full
Abe Lincoln I guess maybe I could but
probably uh well listen for a low energy
guy you're doing a great job over there
I think you're one of the the people
that I try to point to people of look
the guys trying to figure it out and and
I know person I won't even mention some
of the some of the names that we both
come across of people we admire that are
all over the political map that that I
know you get your information from and I
think that's a good thing so you guys
can check out the Greg Gutfeld show on
Saturday nights
10 p.m. right 10 p.m. exactly 10 p.m.
Eastern on Fox News and he's on the five
which apparently is moving to five
o'clock we we cracked the story here
today points at some points and shall
find out and be nine o'clock this week
not a clock this week potentially five
o'clock in the future and all right next
time we're doing this in person my
friend you got it I'll see you soon I
hope
oh and follow him on Twitter it's at
Greg Gutfeld there you go
[Music]
you